we learned in 1957 from a turkey study
where they took 250,000 turkeys and they
put them on a complete turkey pellet
trying to get them to finish for market
within a few days or a week or so of
each other and in the first 13 weeks
fully half of 125,000 of them died
farmers were out there every morning
they picked him up every morning by the
bushel basket Fuld took him to the state
diagnostic lab to see what they died
from when they opened him up every one
of them had died of a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and one of the clever
pathologist says that's got to be due to
a copper deficiency because copper is
required to manufacture the elastic
fibers of arteries and skin and other
tissues and the mechanism of an aneurism
is identical to the mechanism of a
balloon on a weakened wall of a tire you
know when you hit a chuckhole with your
tire and you break the cords the
internal pressure blows a balloon you
overload that tire with weight or heated
up on a highway it blows out same way
with an aneurysm when you have a copper
deficiency you get a breakdown in the
elastic fibers in that artery the
internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain
private artery the coronary arteries the
large arteries AR to pulmonary artery
renal arteries they blow out you die
suddenly just like you've been shot well
and they got excited about this they
doubled the amount of copper in these
pellets the next year they tried to
raise 500,000 turkeys and they did not
lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm they went from a 50% loss to a
0% loss just by adding a little bit of
copper to those pellets so they said
well maybe the same thing is true for
humans in 1958 they started looking at
copper deficiency and various species of
animals and humans and here's what they
found out the very first symptom of
copper deficiency is white gray and
silver hair copper is required as a
cofactor to manufacture hair pigment
doesn't matter if it's blonde Red brown
or black hair and I see a lot of copper
deficiency in this room I can almost
tell you which people men and women who
have colored their hair get pretty good
at that but being a physician and you
don't want to be like a medical doctor
and just treat the symptoms if you're
just coloring your hair you're treating
the symptoms you need to do the basic
thing take some colloidal copper and if
you don't what's going to happen is you
get a breakdown the elastic fibers in
your skin and you started getting crow's
feet around the corners of your eyes in
your mouth parts of your Anatomy begin
to sag and you know you're in trouble
when your doctor tells you look I've got
a golf buddy down the hall whose
Masek surgeon for $10,000 will make you
look 20 years younger but you don't need
a facelift at boobie lived a tummy tuck
or a derriere lift all you need is some
copper and everything will come back up
just like you have a hydraulic jack
under they'll just come right back up
those elastic fibers tighten right up
people say Francine did you get a
facelift you look great you looked like
you're 20 years younger if you don't
take some action at that point the next
thing that happens is you got to break
down the elastic fibers and large veins
of your legs you get varicose veins you
don't take action at that point you get
a breakdown the elastic fibers and large
veins of your exhaust pipe and you get
hemorrhoids so if you have hemorrhoids
varicose veins things that sag wrinkles
white gray or silver here the odds are
you have aneurysms developing in you
somewhere and you don't want to of
course die suddenly of a ruptured
aneurysm when your body's been warning
you for 10 20 30 years just remember
people don't die suddenly of an aneurysm
it may be you drop and die think about
old Albert Einstein he died of a
ruptured aortic aneurysm at 68 years of
age what color was his hair he was
famous for wild white hair wasn't it
now you'd like to think the people who
win the Nobel Prize in medicine but at
least lived to be seventy five point
five but they lived to be 58 just like
other doctors and of course that's
because they are trained and they
believe and they practice you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups doesn't matter if they win the
Nobel Prize or not this guy here dr.
George Kohler was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history 37 years old wins a Nobel
Prize in medicine and he won the Nobel
Prize in medicine for studying
monoclonal antibodies which are
antibodies trained to attack cancer
cells if they ever get this really
working it'll be great because they
won't have to use chemotherapy anymore
which kills more people and it saves 11
years after winning the Nobel Prize in
medicine dr. George Kohler now 48 drops
dead of a cardiomyopathy heart attack
because he believed you can get
everything you need from your for food
rich doesn't take any selenium died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack